بطوله كاس العالم تودع جماهيرها اليوم
وتتويج الفائز لحظه طال انتظارها لكن ماذا
سيحصل للمشجعين بعد متابعتهم مباريات كاس
العالم لمده شهر الخبراء يحذرون من
الاصابه بحمى ما بعد الكاس فالعديد من
عشاق كره القدم يجدون انفسهم يكافحون
الاكتئاب الشديد بعد ان كان يومهم يتمحور
حول المباريات
وبحسب مؤسسه الصحه العقليه الامريكيه فان
نهايه الحدث ستترك لدى البعض فراغا عاطفيا
ويعتبر الحزن والكسل من العلامات المؤكده
على حمى ما بعد الكاس المزيد من التفاصيل
في تقرير التاليه
[موسيقى]
من علامات حمى ما بعد الكاس الكسل الكسل
بس هاي موجوده يعني حمى يوميه
من السعوديه سالنا الجمهور كاس العالم ما
اكثر ما ستفتقده بعد نهايه الماضيه
[موسيقى]
نفس اجواء كاس العالم بصراحه لانه الجوال
ما تتفوت الاماكن كلها مليانه الكافيهات
المطاعم الكل بينتظره اللحظه اللي بشوف
فيها مباراه كاس العالم لانه لحظات صراحه
تحتاج الى واحد توقف عنده واستمتع هذه
اللحظات ما تحصل الا كل اربع سنين
مباريات
للامانه انها جدا حماسيه
السعوديه تاهلوا الكاس العالم
العربي والحماس يعني اول ما فازت المغرب
على طول كل واحد الكورنيش فكان حماس
وانبسطنا كلنا ليونيل ميسي
ان شاء الله راح يرجع بعد اربع سنوات حتى
التجمعات اللي كانت هناك والروح الرياضيه
وكل شيء كان حلو هناك
ميسي كريستيانو
ينضم لنا الدكتور نادر يا دكتور يسعد
صباحك اهلا بك في حسب الدراسه فان جميع
المشجعين متحمسين يصابون بحمى بعد
المونديال وبالاكتئاب لمده شهر كامل بعد
نهايه كاس العالم ما رايكم بذلك هل بالفعل
دراسه دقيقه
الفرصه كل اربع سنوات في ناس بيصير في
تفريخ
حتى للمشاكل اللي في البيت انه بروح يحضر
هذه المباريات انا في عندي اشخاص ما عمرهم
كان لهم علاقه بالكوره في عندي بنات حتى
كانوا يتفلسفوا معي يعني ليش بيلعبوا
الاوت بالايد مش هي كره قدم يلعب
بيصير في هوس بيصير فيه احنا بنقول دائما
اي شيء بيستمر اكثر من 14 يوم او 18 يوم
او لغايه 21 يوم تستمر في المتابعه بنوع
نوع من نمط
الحياه تابعي مجرد يعني لسه كنت بحكي من
اول امبارح يعني خلال يومين اللي مع
بعضيين مع كذا مجموعه من الاصدقاء حتى في
منهم مجموعه بيشتغلوا في الاستثمار المالي
والبنوك
مش لهم كثير متابعه فواحد فيهم بيحكي معي
بالله امبارح بالليل واحنا بنتابع مباراه
المغرب وكرواتيا بيقول لي انا مش متخيل
كيف حكون حياتي بعد كاس العالم قلت له انا
اسف طب هو انت قبل كاس العالم كنت بتابع
مباريات الاهلي
طب انت يعني جديد على الموضوع بس هاي
الاول مره الاستراحه اول مره احضر ومش
متخيل نفسي بعد كاس العالم طب دكتور نادر
ب احنا الدنيا لسه الصبح وبنحب هيك
بنتفائل ويكون في ايجابيه في الحياه هل في
ايجابيات لما بعد كاس العالم لمن منهم
مثلا تاثروا نفسيا بخساره فريقهم بكوا
وتفاعلوا مع اللاعبين المفضلين لديهم
ممكن نتابع المباريات وشوفي اللي جيبات
حصيره تامر على المباريات اكثر رح يصير
ابحث عن الشخص اللي انا حبيته يمكن هتتاثر
بكريستيانو لما كان بيبكي او نيمار لما
كان بيبكي فهيصير يتابع معه يصير شو شو
اخباره في بعض منهم حيصير يشتروا الاشياء
التذكاريه لانه في ناس حتى سالوني في بعض
الاحيان طب احنا انت بتطلع على التلفزيون
ما بتعرفش تجيب لنا ثلاث مش عارف عشان
نحضر مباراه كده فبيسيري تابع بيصير في
عنده اهتمام رياضي الاهتمام رياضي مش فقط
بعض الاحيان بنقول ان احنا خلف الشاشه في
بعض منهم
بيدور طب شو نوع الكوره طب شو ما كتب ليه
الشغل ممكن
تتحول الى متابعات رياضيه فعليه ممكن
بيصير بالفعل انا عاوز اسافر يعني في شخص
بالفعل حصل على التذكره بسعر غالي جدا
وكان اول مره في حياته يطلع على قطر عشان
يحضر مباراه همم فهي هاي القصه هيصير في
نشاط اجتماعي غير النشاط اللي احنا بنتكلم
عليه خلف الشاشه صارت انا انا بتكلم على
اشخاص اعرفهم مباشره صار في عندهم شغف
فيني انا اتابع هذا الرياضه اتابع هذا
الكوره اعرف شو اللي بيصير فيها طيب
الدراسه انصحه حتى انه لابد لتفادي حمى
الممتاز او حمى بعد المونديال الابتعاد عن
العزله وتنظيم هواياتك حتى تخترع هوايات
جديده ما رايكم بذلك ماذا تنصحوني الناس
هتصير في مشكله معه لانه هينتهي اليوم
اليوم نهايه كاس العالم هيصير فيه في
الاخر في فتره طويله شويه على بال ما تبدا
الدوريات الاخرى في هذه الفتره هو الان
بده حاجه احنا بنسميه يعوض بعض الادمان
البسيط اللي صار انا باروح باحضر عليه طول
الوقت المباريات لانه كانت المباريات يوم
يوم
فبيصير الان في التطور تبعه انه يصير يحضر
بعض المباريات الاخرى لا الكوره القدم
وللاسف كمان انتم احنا حكينا على الاجابه
اذا بس بحكي على السلبي فيه اشياء مشاكل
كثيره صارت تحت همم موضوع كاس العالم في
شخص بعدها قبل الاسف تبع والدته في اشخاص
حصل مشاكل ما بينه وبين زوجته في مشاكل
كثير بس هنرجع خلينا نقول الهواس الجيد
انه صار في نسبه متابعه اكثر من الرجال
والنساء لا الرياضه وبالعكس في ناس هتصير
تمارس تلعب بهذه الرياضه في ناس بالعكس
سالوني واحنا في العمر قلت له احنا كبرت
يعني انت اخر مره لعبت كره قدم قلت له من
زمان في مناطق في كل دوله
بياجروا الملعب الرياضي الصغير وبلشه الان
يسالوا انه ممكن نروح نلعب مع بعض
الشهيره انا وابني في مع احد الملاعب
وبنقول للمونديال كبير
شكرا جزيلا دكتور نادر ياغي